ora quer apresentar para vocês então
essa linda moça que tem 22 anos é modelo
ela faz parte do instituto humano down
ela é apaixonada pela vida e vai mostrar
pra vocês como que a ternura pode ter
forma de gente viu até mais com vocês
vitória rosa pegada boa tarde eu sou eu
vim aqui compartilhar um pouco com vocês
eu sou uma jovem cheia de sonhos tal é
que tem um conselho eu já hoje eu faço
parte do mundo do natal que me acolhe
como eu vou lá eu descobri lá eu
descubro e aprendendo várias outras
legais
hoje eu sou modelo do instituto
eu danço filo e faço muitas outras
coisas o do meu maior sonho é casar
hoje eu sou noiva do cavaco e vamos
passar o ano que vem
eu tenho o sonho de ter dois filhos
eles podem ser tal também o meu o sonho
é ser modelo e cantora profissional
eu sou eu vou lutar para chegar lá
porque eu sei quem eu sei que eu voto
hoje eu consigo falar tudo isso porque
eu aprendi a amar a mim mesma eu amo
quem eu sou
o meu conselho para vocês é que sejam
quem vocês são siame bus elaborou e
afaste se escutam vitae aí
domingo